Samantha's in Green Bay Wisconsin hi
Samantha how are you hi thanks for
taking my call I'm good
I just found your program a couple of
months ago and I'm trying to avoid
making another bad decision and I've
started saving up for a house good and I
would really like to buy a tiny house
and I know you you say those are
depreciating assets and so because it's
on wheels and so I just want to the tiny
houses on wheels yeah I don't know if
you've seen any of the programs but
they're like on a trailer it's built
like a real house but you can move it oh
I know what a tiny house is but I didn't
realize you can move them okay yeah you
can hook them up to like a pickup truck
don't you that's not the problem
that's not the problem with those that's
the what I'm referring to with wheels is
the mobile home a trailer and they go
down in value for sure I don't know if
the tiny houses will go down in value or
not I just don't think they're gonna go
up in value like a traditional home and
I wouldn't tie my money up in it for
that reason okay and let me tell you how
I would I base that on okay what makes
something go up in value is the more
people that chase that item the more it
shoots up in value you know what I'm
saying if something is scarce and
there's a lot of people chasing it that
drives the price up you know that makes
sense to you yeah that's basic econ 101
but if there's a flood of the things
then it becomes cheap if there's too
much of it
the problem with tiny houses is not that
they're evil or something like that but
there's going to be a very small
percentage of the population that buys
houses that are going to be interested
in a tiny house and so you don't have
very many people chasing them that's
going to make them not go up as much as
a traditional house a lot more people
will buy regular house would you agree
with that right which means that there's
a lot more market for the regular
which means it's going to appreciate
more and so I would not buy a tiny house
if I were in your shoes I would rather
see you rent a little while and save up
for a down payment on a more traditional
home purchase and get you you know a 15
year fixed mortgage or less or just save
up and pay cash for it if you want to
but I think you're gonna have a harder
time selling the tiny house and I'm
positive of that and harder time than a
traditional house because there's fewer
buyers and as a result they're going to
not appreciate as much if at all I don't
know what they're going to do but
there's no it's a simple econ lesson
from the seventh grade that says you
know it's a supply demand curve that's
what it's called when there is a a lot
of demand for a limited supply it drives
price up when there is a limited demand
for a supply then it drives price down
and and so that that's it's very simple
that way so something that's rare versus
the number of people looking for it
drives the price up and the you know
that's what's going to happen here
there's no way around it